-My first guest
is a World Series champion,
an Emmy-winning baseball analyst
and color commentator,
and a very successful
entrepreneur.
He stars as a guest judge
on a new episode of the popular
show "Shark Tank,"
which you can now see on demand
and on Hulu.
Here is Alex Rodriguez!
Hey, Alex, welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
Thanks for coming on.
You were on our show
back in April,
which was pretty early on
in quarantine.
So thanks for coming on then.
Who'd thought we'd still be here
nine months later on Zoom?
-It's crazy, Jimmy.
It's always so great to see you.
I see you've upgraded --
you're now on your set.
I've upgraded to my bar.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's how long
this has gone on.
-That's exactly
where most people are, yeah.
Yeah, you were in your office
last time, right?
-Yeah, I'm still in my office.
[ Both laugh ]
I made it a bar.
-Exactly right.
I have so many things
I want to talk to you about.
But I was very curious,
'cause you were in Times Square
for New Year's Eve.
I saw you guys
with Ryan Seacrest,
and Jennifer was awesome --
her performance.
Happy New Year, by the way.
-Same to you.
What was it like to be
in Times Square with no people?
-Jimmy, it was crazy.
I've been to Times Square
a million times,
but to be there where --
no fans on New Year's,
I mean, it seems like
for the last hundred years,
you've millions of people
out there,
and hopefully, God willing,
for the next hundred years,
you have millions of people.
But Jennifer killed it.
It was awesome.
But Jennifer
did have a great slide.
I thought that was my job.
[ Laughs ]
-Dude, yeah, yeah.
I'm used to seeing you sliding,
yeah.
She had one of the best slides.
It was -- I mean,
whatever she does always --
she does it the best,
always goes everywhere.
I just saw
you guys are gonna be --
you're headed off to Washington.
-Yeah.
-She's going to be performing
at the inauguration.
-Jimmy, it's been
such a crazy year for her --
I mean, so amazing,
so many blessings.
But to think,
in the span of 12 months,
she's done the Super Bowl,
New Year's,
and now the inaugural --
it's unbelievable.
And what's interesting
is she's most nervous
about Washington, D.C.,
because of the responsibility.
And she wants more than
anything, like all of us,
to bring people together,
to inspire.
And, you know, music and sports
does that better than anything.
And she has
something really cool.
You're going to be surprised.
You're going to love it.
-Really?
-You're going to love it.
-'Cause she always does --
alright, good, good, good.
I don't want to know.
This is so good.
Hey, 2021 --
do you think you guys are
finally going to get married?
[ Chuckling ]
What do you think?
-You know,
we tried twice in 2020.
-I know.
-We got bit twice by COVID-19.
-Yeah.
-You know, they say in baseball,
third time's the charm.
So let's -- let's...
-There we go.
-Let's hope it's...year.
-Alright, good.
I want to talk about
the new season of baseball.
What can you tell us
about the upcoming season?
-Well, I'm excited.
I mean,
we're supposed to start
Opening Day, April 1st.
Baseball and sports -- I mean,
we just need it so much.
We saw football this weekend --
it's so much fun.
But, again, music and sports
bring people together
more than anything
around the globe.
And Commissioner Manfred
just said
that he expects a full season --
not sure
what the fan situation will be.
But Yankees are on fire,
Mets are on fire.
It's gonna be an awesome year.
And I can't wait for 162,
a full season.
-Right? Yeah.
People like seeing you.
I mean, that's why -- I mean,
I see you on "Shark Tank,"
because you're -- you know what
you're talking about.
You've built
a giant business empire.
Is it -- Have you always been
into business,
or is this a thing post-sports?
-Yeah,
ever since I was 10 years old,
I've had
two big kind of goals, as --
I call them the two B's --
right? --
baseball and business.
And I wanted to be like
my father, an entrepreneur.
He also loved baseball.
And I've studied it
for a long time.
We're lucky
we have an incredible team.
We've done some awesome things
in 2020
through
a very, very difficult time.
We've given tons back
to the community.
-Yeah.
-But we're happy
we're taking a public company,
hims & hers,
one of the great telemedicine
companies that we have,
going public.
And then, we're taking another
one public later in the year.
So it's been a very active,
busy year.
We've been growing a lot,
and excited to do more
and give back more.
-Why do you like doing
"Shark Tank"?
-I like it for several reasons.
Number one, I feel like,
on Friday nights,
America is getting
their MBA in business.
That's number one.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Number two,
it's done a lot of social good.
It's deployed over $100 million,
over 25,000 jobs.
My daughters, Natasha and Ella,
ever since they were, like,
little, little, little girls,
I always used to
make them pitch to us
and tell us about
their business ideas.
-Alright, I'm trying to think
of any ideas I can pitch you,
'cause I always try
to pitch you ideas.
I have one idea
for a silent glass.
So, if you're having a cocktail,
I don't want to hear
the ice clink around, you know?
Alright.
That's one idea.
But I don't know how you do it
or if anyone needs it,
but, hey, I like options.
Do I have any other bad ideas?
I have an idea for Oreo.
-Okay.
-I think Oreo should come out
with cookie dough in the middle
of the --
instead of the creme filling.
If Oreos...
-Okay.
-Would...
-You're getting warmer.
-Okay.
[ Both laugh ]
Alright.
I'm trying to think -- Oh!
Then I thought
of another cookie idea
where the inside
is powdered milk.
So, when you eat the cookie,
it turns into milk and cookies.
It's gross -- never mind.
Okay.
I want to --
[ Laughs ]
That was the reaction --
-You saved the worst for last.
It was great.
[ Both laugh ]
-That's the reaction
I want to see, man.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Alex Rodriguez
in "Shark Tank."
Take look at this.
-So there's two rules
in investing, as I see it.
Rule number one
is don't lose money.
-Right.
-Rule number two is
don't forget rule number one.
-Yeah.
-Okay?
So I'm going to make
this investment
as convertible debt.
-Okay.
I'm going to offer you
$200,000 for 20%.
When you hit your 1.8...
-Mm-hmm.
-...it will convert into equity.
-Okay.
-That's my offer.
-You understand
the dilution of that.
-I do.
-Alex Rodriguez, everybody!
Catch him in an all-new episode
of "Shark Tank,"
now on demand and on Hulu.
Alex and I are playing
the "Singing Whisper Challenge"
when we come back.
It's going to be fun.
Stick around.